art I am seriously site to do this
interview right now I have truly wanna
make heroes from wrestling back in the
eighties to movies
to politics and now a guy that i truly
truly admire
and head of the great which is why I
wear these crazy had bone and we're
doing this on some super crazy
high-tech connection governor Jesse
Ventura how are you there
day mom doing terrific are you doing I
am doing well I cannot begin to tell you
the technical hurdles
that we had to jump through to make this
happen but that is the proof that you
truly
are off the grid so can you tell us a
little bit about that just burst of
well i'm ok I'm off the grid I decided
to do with your shot
right after I left office as governor
because I was young enough to go on an
adventure and I decided to do it
show we ventured down your way down shop
at the border about a thousand miles and
I bought a home that time an hour from
pavement in an hour from electricity
and I've been living down here now often
on for going on a
years and now now that I have a show I
may be down here permanently would not
returning to the United States soon
because I love it down your offer great
I love the people where I live
and it's now the creation of my show
are broadcasting back into america as
opposed to looking at america from the
outside looking in
as oppose the inside looking out yet so
why does someone who has commercial
success
as an actor in a wrestler and then who
has political
successes staggering Peru political
success actually
why do you feel that you had to go off
the grid well I didn't feel I have to
but i i just felt I wanted an adventure
I was turning
at the time I would just gone over 50 in
your window of opportunity in time
it got to the point Dave I'll give it to
your blunt yeah when you get to my agent
about sixty years old 62 I am now
time becomes more important than money
and show that was the reason I did it I
want to go on the adventure
I cannot if there's been a map and now I
it's paid off because I have the show
off the grid
yeah I'm not you know we're in a
situation right now
were you criticize the US government
they might kill you with a draw me
closer
they don't well they don't have to take
you to court anymore
they don't have to charge you with a
crime they don't have to go through due
process at all
began to shoot and kill you with a drone
if you come become a problem so
we gotta keep moving down your off the
grid to stay away from those drones
right so this is the stuff that we talk
about all the time over here but you are
actually living
who actually felt that I guess you have
enough influence or
your voice is powerful enough that you
actually felt I assume some sort of
threat I they're not maybe not spoken
but just sort of unspoken as a pair
today or not I never got threaten but I
I wish
I was being blackballed got there the
last book tour
the last book tour I did odd-numbered
the networks NBC CBS or ABC would have
me I'm
Fox won't have me I'm MSNBC won't have
she mm has me on occasionally shore
are this presented an opportunity what
happened I was doing a book tour in
I saw on my schedule larry king and I
for women and Larry retired watch mash
and I walked into a hotel in New York
Camaro was larry king
yeah Larry said I'm on you should I'm on
ora .tv this is where you need to be
ensure we started discussing it now
explain to them I should well there's a
problem
I live off the grid for four to five
months a year
how could I possibly do a show for you
and they should that's not a problem we
have state-of-the-art technology
they should as long as we got energy and
as we get a clear shot up a satellite we
can do your show from anywhere in the
world
and show that row of the event of the
great became the show
we thought Ben let's make rapper Scholl
that were off the grid
broadcasting back to be matched each
much the same I don't know if you're old
enough to remember
but when Wolfman Jack first yep a good
frame a shock jock duty in Iraq
way before Howard Stern up the bush
speak about the Wolfman with all the
teenage kids I remember a
was up but they wouldn't let the Wolfman
broadcast from the United States
sure we had to broadcast from Mexico in
the United States
and that's what we all believed as
teenagers about the Wolfman
so I'm just trying to use a mule Wolfman
Jack thing year
I going outside the country for real and
broadcasting Bakiyev
alright well so let's talk about that
though the heart out why you're outside
the country I mean I think you see this
this country much the way I see it in
it's a country that you love
and you want to be better but seems
really broken right now right
totally are I blame the Democrats and
Republicans both of them
equally as bad as each other they are
the problem they are not the solution
they have been in charge for a hundred
and fifty years now
look at the shape were in I just saw
statistically Dave the other day
a baby born when it takes its first
breath a rare in the United States
lamberth
Muse fifty thousand dollars in debt are
fifty grand in debt
when you take your first prepare who's
responsible for this
the Democrats and Republicans they've
been in charge for a hundred and fifty
years
they've destroyed our country and we've
got to take it back from a piazza
speaking taking it back so you were
someone that you started taking it back
because you
as an independent at the time became
governor I've Minnesota which
in retrospect 02 that almost seem crazy
that that actually worked
because now it almost seems like we
could never have an independent
not true at all not I proved that it
does work and we only raised three
hundred thousand dollars day
ya 98 to elect me governor 300 gram I
actually
made more money being governor than what
I spent to give it
I don't think there's another elected
official nationally
who can make that statement in 50 years
yeah that they made more money doing the
job done what be spent to get it
know it could happen I'll tell you right
now I
all Palmatier Bowl here we are on page
program
I'll give you a bold prediction into it
with their iPad
if I did get ballot access in all 50
states
and if I would guaranteed to be allowed
in the debates
I would be your next president in 2016